on this week's show how to secure a
no-money-down lease option agreement in
the news we look into the new tenant fee
ban and we're gonna be answering all
your property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
I almost leads I'm Alistair Cunningham
and welcome to this week's property
investors podcast it's gonna be a really
good show you know a lot in the news
recently about the tenant feed bounts
are gonna be delving into map we kind of
got inspired but I'm sure many of you
watch this bit will have been watching
the for listening to this have been
watching the eviction if you haven't
seen it go and check it out hashtag the
evictions on YouTube and last week or
yeah it would have been episode 3
episode 3 they secured a lot of lease
options and we thought you know
obviously it's something that we've both
done so if you teach but we thought we'd
delve into a bit about how they did it
so quickly because it was was impressive
the speed crazy I remember when I was I
was actually out with them because I was
following them what round for the the
three things they're three days and they
had a few days to do a 72 hours yeah but
I was following them around and and it's
amazing what happens when you put a bit
pressure on somebody to get something
done by a set time because normally the
metal ions yeah deadlines that's there's
a lesson here isn't that when you say
yourself a task say a deadline to it but
they were like machines and do you know
what it was a bit of a I think it was a
bit of hard week because we had to evict
three people I don't think any of them
needed deserve to be evicted no because
they all they all pulled the whale what
I thought was funny though was like week
one and week two everyone was like we
want James that one James out and then
we throw money decoy everyone was like
oh watch give it James it's like you
can't win yeah well sorry for in though
I must admit because he probably done it
was him he secured to do let's face it
yeah he was the strongest candidate and
that team it like it was although there
was a few M people commenting on the the
YouTube saying like
why did Courtney just like donate
herself to leave she said I'm done I'm
going why was that I mean I think that
she genuinely felt the she what desert
because three of them had to go yeah and
I think she just thought it's not fair
that I was quite admirable really isn't
it that she's a I know business you've
got to be you've got to fight to the end
but if she knows she genuine didn't
genuinely didn't pull her weight then
yeah she sort of sacrificed herself for
the greater greater good of the
teamspeak and without we were meant to
be last wasn't say we've been up to last
week we were meant to be together
weren't we we wear but we weren't
let me tell you what happened guys so we
we were to go on a training course in
Spain mm-hmm for a whole week although
becoming a warrior and being as warrior
Enlightenment camp nothing stops you
nothing stops you get there no matter
what happened yeah push through the
barriers and what meets your fears what
time we supposed to be meeting so I left
my house I think our flight was five
o'clock yeah we went to meeting the
airport three went to three o'clock ish
I left my home and you phoned me on when
I was on the way in said hey man how you
doing how you getting now how long would
be to get the airport and I'm like I'm
literally ten minutes away and I said
I'll see you now I'm gonna go I'm gonna
check in I'll see you in ruins on the
see you on the inside so then I'm sat
there it get the little coffee shop
we've got nothing was a cost our
Starbucks whatever with my little coffee
I got a little a little M like peanut
bar and then I'll just sitting there a
little peanut bar sitting there I'm a
little peanut bomb a little coffee
thinking busy you'll be here soon
flights winning like an hour away you'll
be here soon as two hours waste but I
called you back and then I'm listening
to music and in my phone rings and I
thought highs through the gates he's
just ringing to find out where I am and
he rings up and he goes hey man hey hey
doom we have a problem
you know all right I can't find my
passport
he lost his passport him and Anna both
didn't have the passports and they were
rummaging around everywhere trying to
find the passports I figured because we
obviously were on Saturday the program
wasn't till Monday so I just thought oh
well I'll find it tomorrow I'll just
catch another flight no no big a yeah
thought it was two hours two hours of
desperate stress looking for it where I
could have still caught the fly yeah
at which point I didn't and I thought
okay well this thing logically literally
tore my house it's everywhere toys kids
toy boxes I've got no idea cuz I had all
four of them yeah I'm gonna be saying
yeah I had in my bag I don't know I'm
confused
anyway yes one I unfortunately missed it
I looked trying to get another passport
the same day I looked at trying to catch
a train trying to catch a ferry still
need a passport I know good crossing the
border you know I found that if you go
from Island to Spain you don't need a
passport if you're if you're European
citizen okay so if you're but and you
can get from here to Ireland about
anything possible either right okay and
I was like perfect
but if you're from the UK you know we're
not part of that little Club no no we
still need a part I still need a
passport it was just so I have a
question for you hmm have you found your
passport yet no we've got no idea I
reported it lost absolutely not just you
as it's all for you more than you hold
all our family for passports gone that's
crazy that's crazy but I'm sure do you
know some men and I genuinely believe I
was gutted that you can really actually
wars because I was looking forward
spending some time here and Anna and I
was just I was a bit gutted II didn't
make it but I think it was for the best
yeah I do I'll tell you why because on
that that training thing a camper went
on it was all about putting yourself out
there and pushing yourself and and
pushing through barriers and just going
and then both both realizing the best
for you best for me yeah great I don't
mean no no I'll tell you why because I
think listen we had to be up every every
morning it like stupid o'clock in the
morning and we had to be in the training
room at 6:00 a.m. I'm used to that well
kids yeah
I'm used to it as well but I'm not used
to doing yoga from 6 a.m. to 6:15 a.m.
and then from whatever time to like
another 45 minutes doing morning
movements you know more on the movements
are basically it's where they pump the
music like you're in a nightclub and you
have to just dance like nobody's
watching
it's it that's him in the morning and I
don't think I would have played full-out
if if I knew people there hmm and so I
think that's why I'm saying it was
probably bass use didn't come but I
actually gave everything and I played
full-out and I loved it and I'm not
gonna talk too much about it because I
know you're gonna call next year if
you've got your passport back but I know
you're gonna go next year yeah and I
don't know ruin it for you but it was
truly amazing awesome
I'm really glad anyway she move on with
the show yeah so not to cut you off but
famous yeah awesome so first on how to
secure a lease option agreement so first
of all I mean it was your team did
better than my team in all fairness
yeah they secured a lot like they
secured so on the very first day we
secured our a lease option agreement and
in principle with a guy in a guy so
let's take it from the very best ok how
did they where did they find where did
they find that lead that was a Gumtree
lead come true it was on gumtree it was
for a property in Darby just around the
corner from Anthony Jones actually no it
was in Crewe so it was crew it which is
trying to confirm Anthony Jones house
and so he knew of the property because
he's passed there a few times but then
he sought on gumtree so then there was a
phone number so they rung up the book
did they wait and see yeah and the
vendor was wale up for it however the
numbers weren't great and the property
neither needed a lot of walked into it
that was the one that you said to them
that it's not gonna happen I actually
said to him look this is not a viable
deal just because it's a lease option
and it's it's technically just free and
it's only legals just because it's free
doesn't mean you should take it and I
actually advised him to walk away from
it and they were gutted they were like
no no no we're gonna do it and like
listening it's just not a good deal
don't do it so we had that in the back
burner that was always going to be there
if we wanted it they then went to a and
a couple of state agent
they actually literally just just we'd
be parked up in Derby city centre and
they all go no no it was Darby we moved
we went from rulers Darbar Darby I cut
him exactly like that locations but
anyway we went to our city Emilia - just
parked up in the local task was car park
and they went into town sent need to
start going into state agents and just
asking estate agents if they've got any
properties that are like completely not
salt sailing you know not been on the
books for a long long time and you
didn't get anywhere with that to be
honest um but then they found a mortgage
broker and but it's a spatial mortgage
broker it's not like a high street Linda
um and they phoned them up and they got
chatting to this lady I think lady's
name was Lisa I believe right now mm-hmm
and then they went to see her and it
turns out she completely gets lease
options she completely understands rent
to rent she understands property
investing and she had late Lords she had
hundreds of properties available not
only stockbroker
she's a mortgage broker and I was like a
fan out a property advisor mmm so she
does creative financing for a property
very very interesting women very
interesting business and they deal with
a lot of portfolio sales they don't
really deal with individuals and they
it's like it's weird stuff so like
blocks of apartments blocks of them like
houses or not blocks of houses but like
rows of houses as opposed to just one
house and pubs commercial units and
commercial resi units things that are
they deal with all that stuff and and
they've got connections which they get
all their deals from this one person as
far as my way yes no no no no no they
got what they got em do you know the the
four apartments they got on a lease
option they've got four apartments on a
lease option and Darby Susannah
that came from that lady yeah and then
they did also get another one that John
Reybold secured and that was via Gumtree
lead and that was our rent to rent HMO
that was one where the guy was they were
written out for like fifty quid a week
per room ah yes and they managed to
negotiate that as well but the the
connections they made that they were
phenomenal and the thing is so what
advice them back bet bearing that in
mind what advice would you give to a
viewer who's watching this who thinks
you know what
I fancy getting myself a lease option
yeah
what would you block off I mean it's
interesting isn't it when like when
Samuel does for example the financial
freedom challenge any blocks off a
couple of weeks or a week or whatever
they absolutely go would you do that if
you were at work would you go okay well
I'm gonna book a week off work yeah and
I'm just gonna fully immerse myself and
throw myself in Gumtree leads right
right me yeah going in viewing agents do
you know I would do go on
and I think we should do this at some
point in the next year odd cast special
a podcast but I think we should your
podcast special right where we give
ourselves one week all right and we work
as a team or against each other I don't
know what do you guys think what do you
guys say right interesting
okay so meet me versus you we can either
give herself a week or we can give
herself three days whatever I don't know
it doesn't matter right not four days so
I got three whatever we can give us have
a period of time not too long not too
short um right definitely again and we
should give ourselves that challenge of
we have to secure normally don't deal in
that period of time and just completely
immerse yourself in it so pick an area
and that's you really do you did that
with some in America I've done it Samuel
Samuel but this big groundbreakers
Graham beacon is for us to do it is for
you can do it I could do it
no no anyway three days right three days
yeah and we have gone get a no money
down I know my damn deal they got a
normally done deal that if they fall
through that deal and they purchase at
the end they stand to make I'll put two
hundred thousand was it real or it was
crazy sums of money that live actually
as the team leave joint ventured
together and they've set up a company
together and they've done it as our eyes
that does the team was not one person
what they work as a team and planning's
really fear and and just see what
happens but if you're watching this and
you want to do something like this just
immerse yourself
allocate two or three days or a week
where nothing you do nothing but
property
no no sort of social media
no TV no friends nothing like just get
out there get into agents start the
flick Gumtree and for a whole week just
focus on what you're trying to do and
what is that what should they do look
for not lament that are normally don't
deal with that's the goal that's the
goal yeah you need to get out there they
need to get meeting agents scouring
Gumtree scouring social media for leads
not for forget social media for fun for
leads
it was interesting get to networking
events because like this team went to
networking event every night and I'm
you'll I think teaches lease options
really really well at the crash he
teaches the script how to say that what
to say all that sort of stuff
well I've secured several by following
on that script interesting seeing Ricky
because he very much tried to follow I
can't did he fall I come in because I
saw Ricky do various Ricky practices
this what love about Ricky and he'll go
in and do a certain way of doing it and
then he was tweaked it for the next time
and I knew took it for the next time it
didn't do it like he didn't do it
exactly how I did it but I could see the
thread I could see yeah the patterns
yeah yeah Ricky was actually very good
he was he was very good in that task
because when we arrived at a networking
event and we were all in the car waiting
because we were like the first people
they are and as a car come in he was
like back a minute guys and he would get
out of the car as it as it pulled into
the space he was like hey are you here
for the networking event and he was like
banging on the window were you for the
networking event I just wanna talk to
you I'm looking for houses if you like
me house did you look at the sale and
then they would say no and he's like I
need a drink I'll just back in a minute
and even come back it's hilarious
it really was Ricky knows at one about
well God that Ricky knows Ron about it
was funny
Rick him and Ricky
thank you edit em but no it was really
good but he was really he was hustling
he was hustling everyone it turned up at
that car park was it mostly every day
yes they all we're not just Ricky though
we're Antony was John was Hannah and
Ricky John raised two thousand pounds
and like that so don't tell me you can't
raise money so what are the steps then
let's break it down right step one
so in step one set some time aside yeah
say that was their crazy little sign on
the script yeah yeah learn how it all
step one get educated good crash course
it's free you don't have to pay anything
it's free your time and that's it okay
say it to crash course crash course
it'll to book a defined period of time
to get out there and start meeting
people yeah step three
turn off all your social media for fun
forget fun for this week you're there to
work okay so no TV no socializing just
fun and only socialize if it's for a
business just fun no no no fun
only socialize only socialize if it's
just for business okay just that we just
that week just this is what I'm working
with this guy commit fun know you can
have fun but commit for that one week
you'll not regret it you know have fun
with its controlled fun controlled find
yeah yeah yeah right step 4 yeah get out
there every single day and get out there
in your area be walking the streets you
say gum tree and gum tree open rent
spare room all these places focus
brokers any mortgage brokers that do
creative finance in the area smaller
estate agents yeah there's no point but
I personally wouldn't phone numb now go
in because I'll tell you why because
they get phone calls day in day out from
people that are looking for deals it
make the effort dress smartly go in and
actually see if you can sit down with
them for five minutes 10 minutes what
just you in yeah cause you went dress
smartly
alright so just get in there and
actually sit in front of people your
people relate to people and if you fall
numb up you'll just end up s on the end
of a phone get in there and get me in
people walk the streets go and see
houses get inside property and if even
if it's a problem it's on Rightmove I
secured a lease option from a property
that was advertised for sale on
Rightmove so don't tell me it can't be
done so I've done it I'm done I can't it
can be done it can be done you may not
want to do it I can
[Laughter]
so just get out there get meeting people
Network like crazy get to a networking
event yeah everywhere listen and what
you do the networking we trying to find
em so when you go to most networking
events you'll get offered the
opportunity to do a twenty second pitch
so to stand up introduce yourself tell
people why you're there
always do that and then when you're
there
everybody don't be sat down with your
arms crossed thinking this is boring get
up there get talking to people can you
give us an example of a 20 second pitch
I've been that big of yeah sure so when
I time yeah yeah it's less than 20
seconds but when I go to a networking
event and I'm let's say I'm looking for
investors for my my source in business
no you're not you're looking for a lease
option agreement okay
this is my twenty second lease option
pitch alright pitch we might have to cut
this and do this again some might mess
up you're not gonna get this perfect
right so practice it okay
I know I've seriously put you on the
spot it's fine asthma warrior man like
listen but you might not get this right
first time and if you may setups or what
but practice before you go so let's
pretend I'm like rousting yet because
anyone else want to give a twenty second
pitch I mean twenty second elevator
pitch no I'll go oh oh you you there in
the chickie shirt okay are you ready so
I would stand up I'm not gonna stand up
cuz I'll be away from the mic yeah clear
my throat
go ahead Alastair we were doing how did
you know my name is Alastair I have not
introduced myself I saw you on this
brilliant pod cuz you're a sidekick to
that Russell Leeds guy right let's say
this would be my twenty second pitch go
F air I'm at an event I would stand up
and say hey my name's Alistair
Cunningham I am looking for investment
properties using creative strategies so
if you're looking to offload a property
that may be a negative equity please
come and see me in a break I would love
to help you
14 seconds pretty good yeah pretty good
and that was just off the cuff and I
didn't stutter I didn't get my words
wrong
and I've never asked first never have
done that page my normal pitch when I go
to networking events is hey my name's
Alistair Cunningham I own a comedy
called beta source limited I match up
tired landlords and investors if you're
looking to offer to property please come
see me in a brick that's how I get
investors on my database guys and you
heard it here first seven seconds yeah
doesn't have to be long do you know what
you know what these twenty second
pictures should be twenty seconds they
shouldn't be twenty seconds but it's a
maximum twenty seconds my point being
would you say that twenty seconds just
long enough I think I think's long
enough and I think it's also a little
bit too long you think it's too long
tell you why you could if you lasted
seven seconds it acceptable one-pot
wonder it's dreadful but it's always
good listen right the seven seconds of
magic the time doesn't matter now you
think that the quality is good for me
good for you okay um do you know um I
feel an appeal of a shade of red here
anyway um right listen the your pitch
should be direct to the point nobody
gives a rip about your life story
they don't care okay so don't stand up
and preach them and tell them about your
life so they don't care me all they want
to know is how you can help them I say
this to everybody I teach about how to
network and how to find investors do not
try and sale when you do your twenty
second pitch because available every
other person at that networking event
they're trying to sell something you
need to come from a position of I'm
trying to help you so make it short
snappy directing to the point don't
waffle don't go on and don't talk
rubbish last twenty minutes
but direct to the point and a lot I
wanna colored like don't waffle don't go
and don't don't say stuff for the sake
of saying it exactly say right guys
listen direct them to the point because
do you know what if it's a good 20s if
it's a good
seven or eight second pitch yeah that's
better in a [ __ ] twenty second pitch is
it not yes yes let me get you twenty
second page so gone come on go what am i
pitching that you trying to find people
to help them release options okay hi my
name is Russell I'm a property investor
and I'm looking to help investors we've
got properties that they're trying to
offload so if you've got a property
that's not work if you didn't want to
get rid of please come and see me in the
break mine was bare but yeah that was
fairly alright I suppose
again off the calf but yeah listen it
can be it's got to be your pitch make it
personal but the waffle you have you
heard it here first the the the the
greatest irony is well we're talking
about lease options everything if you've
got time and I can perhaps tell you
about how I secured one of my lease
options may tell us go ahead right we
would love to hear it good right okay so
one of my lease options property was on
Rightmove I cannot remember the exact
figure so I'm not going to talk about
the figures because it's it was like a
year and a half ago and I just can't
remember them and probably was on
Rightmove for around about 90,000 nice I
think was May 6th I was in pound
I actually secured that property for an
investor because it would make a great
for bed hmm and we put an offer in I
think it was nine e 1000 we offered on
it and it got accepted
pause for dramatic effect
it was pourcel could remember anyway
we've all forgot accepted I then sold
that to an investor yeah as our package
deal happy days properties gone through
I've got a text message from the
investor but 4 weeks later saying that
the vendors have had to pull out of the
deal now the reason the vendors had to
pull out the deal was because they were
a negative equity and the the mortgage
company wouldn't allow them to sell the
house and this they could pay the
balance off yeah but they weren't in a
position to pay the the balance off the
mortgage even after a completed it they
wouldn't needed about twelve thousand
pounds they didn't have that money so
they had to pull out that they own now
I'm like Samuel teachers discipline your
disappointment so I was a bit annoyed
because I've got an investor where the
deal was fallen through
so I've got to then look after him and
I've also like just lost a deal as well
now it's a really good really good
potential for bed hey Jamal I just lost
the deal
couldn't do anything with it so I I add
a bit of a moat for a day or two
and then I realize and I thought hang
about I can I'm able to help me another
way however it's true an estate agent so
you don't actually know who the a their
person owns houses so I've done the
usual a wrong that stage and I'm I said
look I could still buy that house but it
would be through a creative way and I
says is there any chance you can ask the
vendor to contact me and then see if we
can help them and I assured agent Luke I
says if it works I'll still pay your fee
whatever that may be I'll still pay you
so for your time so you're not gonna
lose any of the deals I said I'm also
very happy to design something to say
that I will what do you think they said
I think they they wanted I would imagine
they would still want you to run it by
them any what was going on and still
good then be the middleman well they
actually said no they wouldn't even
entertain it wouldn't even entertain it
um so I I tried to convince him again I
said Luke I'll even pay your fee now if
you can hold if I said I'll pay your fee
now but you have to put that into like
an escrow account or a holding account
and if it doesn't work you giving me it
back and they still wouldn't go for it
which I found bizarre so I was being
very open and open and honest with him
at all times didn't happen so then I I
started looking around trying to find
that same property because I knew they'd
rented that out previously as a single
layer so I started trying to looking
around the internet trying to find it in
archived webpages because if you look on
the internet you can look at archived
pages and I actually managed to find it
on a kind of what site it was wrong but
was on a site and I said I found out who
the agent was that was advertising the
property and I just sent them an email
saying look I'm interested in buying
this property and all their struggling
sell because they were negative equity
can you please forward my details to
them and ask them to contact me and I
never thought I'd hear from them
never could you've used my registry yeah
but it doesn't it comes up as though I
did try less but it came up as the the
address of the property so even if I
send a letter there they're not gonna
get it it didn't
come up is their personal home address
and told me their name but then I try so
I tried to find them on social media but
there was lots of them because they've
got like not a common name but there's
there's not like an analogue alastair
coming up no it's not like there's
probably only one of me to be honest
and I am unique yes with it you know
it's funny it's funny because like it's
quite an unusual name I still it shows
Russell Leeds and Samuel Leeds
there's not many yeah so anyway and
especially your middle name didn't use
middle name I found I didn't realize it
still the other day but your middle I
was sorry it's ker no it's not kei are
happier here he Kei Archaea I prance
Hasker I was the killer
Cunningham notes out the Kier Cunningham
drifting off point do you don't hit
about 22nd pitch about not waffling we
need to put that in description we also
reveal Alistair's crazy middle name
right yeah let's go so I I found this a
stage and I asked them to get the
vendors to contact me and I honest never
thought I'd hear from them and I but
about a month went by and I got a random
email from somebody saying hi I've been
giving you deals by this company I
honestly did I own this property I'd be
happy to discuss with you if you if you
still looking to buy the property and I
so I thought okay Brian so I then I
contacted them we had some phone calls
it happened it this property took like
six months to complete - a long time
because there was lots of going back and
forth with negotiations did you say I'm
building trust with me and there wasn't
the obviously they've never heard of
this before and you know what really
worked
I wasn't pushy I wasn't like we've got
to do it we've got to do it we've got to
do it I'm like listen I get you don't
understand this I get it cuz it's it's
an unheard-of thing for a PTIN they 90%
of the population they probably haven't
heard of it
and I said so once Peter solicitor you
can speak to your solicitor if you want
or you can speak to our solicit we
recommend who specializes in this and
she says well I'll speak to you as if
they specialize in it so they spoke to
our solicitor and and our solicitor is
not there to sell our
for us no salient for us they're there
to represent them one of the things that
I always finds really annoying when you
get to this stage is when they come is
when they do want to speak to their own
they've got oh we've got a family system
using your are this deal is not gonna
get through yeah the reason is because
family solicitors don't understand it
because they might specialize in family
soliciting stuff or even if it is their
property source at lease they won't get
it and this is a specialized field thank
you give it up to our boy Nick man he's
awesome he always gets us drinks and
he's he's an awesome film or filmography
film or before you make it worse
videographer awesome man yes so
basically the this list it's not like
sale it for you they're there to
represent the buyer the vendor the
vendor and not even they don't represent
ours and in this case actually cost me
more money
I know because he negotiated a worse
deal because it was better for them
which I'm fine with
because I want it to be win-win all
property should be win-win he's not
bitter about I'm not bitter I know I'm
not actually bitter at all and not
really at all because it was good for
them and I don't want them being in a
situation where they resent what's going
on I want them to actually feel do you
know what I also really helped me
because I have really helped them and do
you know what the property's only just
been finished because we had to do a bit
of work to it I've paid that money every
month to them every day on on day first
of each month every month no but I'd
feel so now the mortgage is getting paid
they're not in arrears anymore they're
happy it just it just shows doesn't it
it just shows that you need to be aware
of what you can do just look for that
get out there like we said get out there
and just look for the opportunities and
I'm a great believer of putting your
feet on the ground boots on the ground
yeah I don't mean oh you do it right
there I mean boots on the ground so when
you're a property investor and you're
looking get out they are get meeting
agents get looking at property because
deals will come to you naturally mmm
very very very very well hopefully you
guys have found that helpful it is now
time for this
[Music]
so it's time for our in the news section
and in the news this week we're gonna be
talking about the new the tenant fee ban
okay there's been talk about this for
what 18 months yeah it's been a long
time as I remember I remember
has it been enforced is it I think was
July 1st wasn't it it's coming in on the
1st of June so yeah I think it's
possible I know I mean you might be
right
it's coming in very soon yes it's
imminent I was you might be what I think
it is July it's coming in very soon
Karim of the day
so yes it's coming in next month
basically what it means this is that
letting agents and landlords are no
longer allowed to charge a fee for
example I mean if you've ever been a
tenant no ok so you'll know you know
when you're a tenant so tenancy set up
fees viewing fees credit checks
eventually checkout fees fees for
cleaning yeah none of that stuff you're
not allowed to charge what I knew it was
coming by didn't or was that deep so
like fees for cleaning so you're not to
charge if a tenant leaves the house in a
dump you know I'll charge them for the
cleaning no that's ridiculous you can
charge them obviously things like rent
rent is on the list you're out stars
even rent a deposit but the deposit has
been capped to how much five weeks rent
okay it's not a bad thing no I think
that's put that's pretty good that's
pretty good yeah there's early early
termination things like that you can do
you can still charge yeah I'm not sure
what I think I mean doesn't really it's
good for the 10 and obviously because
they can then move house and it cost
them less money and you don't have to
pay all these fees because some of the
fees do mount up than they like if
you're looking to move house on if
you're looking to move to another
entered a competition like you might
have to have quite a considerable chunk
of money to actually do that yeah so it
does add up but I know quite a few
estate agents it's no effect in their
business of course it is that's where
they make a lot of their money I know I
do think it takes to pee though like
when I move house I always think that
they
overcharge bear in mind they're taking a
commission of the rent as well for the
job that they actually do I do think
they overcharged what they'll what what
I'm sure they'll do is they'll pass that
fee on to the landlord yeah somebody's
paying it still and as a result the
landlord will put the rent up so the
tenant will pay in in the end you just
don't know it it's not gonna be out
front up front so they may it might be
increasing it I wonder I wonder if over
the next of 12 months we're gonna start
seeing rents go up a little bit to cover
that and because like I know on estate
agent who's now had to because they
can't do 10 fees they've now started
doing a like a 360 degree tour of a
property by video and by things that are
so they charge for that and they also
charge live to started a little cleaning
business on the side and for doing deep
cleans and properties and things ask was
to other income streams to cover all the
tenant fee bands yeah so yeah is people
still got their money do you not mean so
these businesses are going to have to
diversify and look at other income
streams you'll imagine that's a big
portion of their income tenant turn fees
but to be fair to be fair it's not
really that should the tenant be paying
like all like for a credit check and
always a bit it's not well cost money
doesn't it so why shouldn't they because
they don't want it's not something that
they they want is it doesn't matter they
want to move house yeah they should pay
the monthly fee to live in the house
yeah but whitewash the fees do take the
pee it's a good point actually you know
like you know if you go and if you can
buy a car right and they you buy on
finance don't charge you for the
correction they don't steal you by the
way it's 75 pound for a credit check
yeah yeah it's good point out the feed
the fees do take the pay they really do
because I just typical I've never rented
okay so what is the typical moving cost
for fees well for me i the bigger the
house the more expensive obviously have
been I often end up spending a few grand
on Wow okay I include including you
deposit yeah but but no yes only like
two two and a half three grand I got my
deposit which was normally what would
the deposit be a night late
- last round she's done - an off ground
so it deposit to enough ground yeah and
how much what what were the fees on that
or what were the fees on top of that so
the fees on top of that I can't remember
in detail because I just actually pay it
yeah but you've got to pay light just
like random admin fees like admin fee
for I couldn't dig the contract out and
tell you but its admin fees but this
happening fees for that you got to pay
for the crazy see it was about a
thousand pound or less more or less than
a thousand it was quite a lot it was I
remember thinking it's obviously I
remember thinking it does they do take
the mick yeah with the fees so I don't I
don't think that it's necessarily a bad
thing and I think it would be fairer on
the tenant as well you have it the
spread spread over like why it's all why
can't we cap it like why couldn't they
say why instead of abolish and it
completely why don't these cap it and
see like the maximum fees you can
charges like two hundred and fifty quid
because that's not unreasonable as a no
and then the thing is that is that they
charge way more I think like the credit
check it was like for me it was 75 pound
do you know my script it cost there's a
lot less than that I think it's like 12
quid yeah and if you if you join the
same companies out there that way if you
get a membership you can do them for
like three quid yeah and which they
obviously they obviously will ask is the
agent so they'll have all these it
doesn't cost that much 35 quid for the
first person 25 I think I said 100 quid
in credit fees they're just everywhere
they can it's like anything isn't it
anywhere they can make money they do so
they have taken the mick I've been
exploiting a little bit in yeah I think
so I think so they've shot himself in
the foot a little bit I can't remember
the fees are paid exactly because like
it's not we're not talking mega money
yeah yeah but it but for something in
fairness I'm gonna cut in here in
fairness you you're not a poor guy
Russell you can afford it but what if
you're at the other end of the scale we
are you perhaps can't afford this yeah
and like if you're if you're living in
an expensive earring you know I'm the
move and that's another maybe two
thousand pounds on top of the move some
people just haven't got the money you
get back yeah it's deposited but you
still need that cash
she still need the cash you still need
to be able to say yeah there's the money
cuz that money's no a lot still yours
it's held somewhere you can't use that
and we hope we also we argued as well
not long ago and part of the reason with
the we talked about the the rule section
21 but the truth is is you could pay
this thousand pound or whatever to move
in and then in six months time they
could just go right out now and you have
to pay all over again yeah so crazy you
know is I don't realize it was such a
big deal I just thought it was like
maybe tenant fees were like maybe 150
quid you don't really see it no you
don't like the letting agent deals event
deal with it well obviously when we were
in quick move it was just hecho Mo's so
it was very weakly charged I think the
admin fee which I was 150 quid and that
good point so like do you know like like
my HTML probably is they charge see but
they charge me this they don't charge at
any I'll charge both yeah so like so
this I wasn't I don't get involved with
that set of things I have a management
company and they deal with it I don't
wage we used to charge 250 quid to the
landlord's for a finder's fee attendant
finder's fee and 150 quid to the tenant
for an admin fee Wow okay yeah so that
was but but you wouldn't be able to
charge that yeah idle bit of a heart
attack yesterday speaking about
management companies I got my monthly
statement from my management for one of
my properties and I normally get about
thirteen hundred pound a month from this
property and the the statement come
through and it said yeh we've
transferred your monthly payment to you
and it's 308 pounds and I'm thinking
about is it's our wish the rest of the
rent and so I was like this open that
like one o'clock in the morning and I'm
like haven't like I'm like what the hell
is going on why wouldn't got like one
person's rent turns out it's all fired
it's because they've just changed their
payment system so some of the tenants
are on the new system some are on the
old system and in this probably one
person's on the old system so that's
what's come through a 308
but the other tenants are on the new
system so that's going to come through
in a couple of days but it was just like
that moment of my
none of my tenants have paid the rent
this month but now they're all up today
but I'm sure they'll do is they'll pass
the filter onto the is a bit of a pain
from app one of you because first but I
suppose it's fair because we're the ones
that are using their service the the
tenant but again paid yeah as long but
missus anything have to be more
competitive aren't they the problem is
they're passing it on to the tenant
who's got no control hmm no choice no
control and what they're doing is making
it cheap for the landlord to get the
landlords in and they're putting the
field and the tenant wants the house
yeah they've got no choice I never felt
like I had a choice doesn't even look at
it it was just like worth or what that
house just cost I've got to pay but it
is taking the pee I actually think
there's to be unpopular view for a
landlord I actually think as someone
that's sitting on both sides of the
fence we do think it's another massive
benefit of being a tenant as well by the
way so you can look at it from I
actually think that it is fair hmm maybe
not to abolish it completely maybe they
should paid the actual cost yeah but I
think that I actually even if it was 250
even if you just said look 10 fees are
250 quid and kappa across country i
don't know me i'm not a state agent I
let an agent I wouldn't know I think
that's not unreasonable is it no it's
not reasonable
not really but interesting thing goes
that's the news anyway right it's now
time for this so it's now time for us to
answer all your questions if you want to
get your questions answered on another
episode comment your questions below in
the youtube video we will be having a
look through there but what we mostly do
we do a Facebook live in the property
investors with Samuel Leeds Facebook
group where we basically just say hey
we're about to film the show you got any
questions and then by the time we get to
the this part of the show we've normally
got a load of questions to go through so
if you want to if you want to get on the
show in your name on the show and your
question answered
check out that group and look for us out
on there so who has so we have a couple
we've got quite a few questions today
we're going to answer my kales question
first even in your position even in your
positions of success do you still
receive any type of main
ship mmm good that's a very good
question yes absolutely
why is that Russell well because you
never if you're not growing you're dying
yeah
and because we think education is what
education is vital in it's vital it's
crucial to my home success if you're
Samuel still gets education of course
he's born as he not flying out to
America on July 4 we're going to get me
both grunting oh yeah yeah we know our
training programs but also David for me
intro gone gone don't mention this
actually cuz to Nick this morning famous
saying it's true as well five people
that you hang around with yeah
a what I can't member that exact same
but roughly yeah that you become I can't
sing so if you hang around with I
positive people you're the six yeah if
you hang around five no beds you're the
six yeah but here's my point right not
nowadays we live in a in a world where
you can connect with people you don't
have to necessarily physically hang out
with them not so for example Samuel does
a YouTube video every single day yeah if
you watch that and immerse yourself in
that you're basically hanging out with
Samuel and positive people yeah he
becomes one of the people that you hang
out with if you read positive books by
but by authors you're hanging out with
those offers kind of physic not like
physically but you but that's what
you're immersing yourself in so for me I
mean I'm continually reading books
mindset books property books business
books I'm continually going on courses
so I don't have like a particular mentor
per se I don't have someone who s see
this just it last year you went on lots
of training courses last year do you
know what you went to Germany you went
to India hmm he went generally twice
actually think I was Jo me twice went to
India yeah I'm going this young into
America and of course America we're
supposed to be in space festival in
Spain bomb guy I've got one about I like
to go
something I want to go and a Joe
Dispenza once coming up see I want to
get on that I want I like to go on stuff
every couple of months maybe three or
four months yeah yeah yeah yeah so like
from myself I'm always educating we are
actually going away so we are leaving
tonight to go and film the podcast live
tomorrow in London and then we're at an
event for two days in London yeah I was
in Spain last week and August I'm going
to Jeremy to do it using last year then
I'm going to India in December you have
to travel around the world to do this
but yeah it's nice what she said is nice
it puts yourself in the environment
there so yeah always I've got lots of
people that I look up to in different
areas one other little thing I'll say
right so I've just come back from Spain
and I made lots of really nice people
there and we've also set up a whatsapp
group together and even that is helpful
because it's full of positivity and it's
people pushing you on and be nice to you
same-same well exactly not from that one
time being on that one but yeah you lost
your passport yeah you know great
question right next for sure okay this
is from Liana Leah Nora Fletcher I'd
like to know what the course of action
is with a tenant that suddenly goes into
long-term care into prison or get
sectioned or unlikely unlikely to return
to the property
what can you then do about non-payment
if there's say four or five months left
on the tenancy can you cancel turns it
or do you just have to keep it and live
well we actually had that so we had a
tenant who was staying it was one of our
HMOs and he went to prison okay so we
just cancelled his tenancy and filled
his room yeah I was gonna say you as
long as you don't throw his possessions
out there'll be a clause in the contract
that says that if something that they
should be a clause in the contract
somewhere that says if if they go into
the prison or section the way of are and
they're not there and they can't pay the
rent then there's a there's a way out of
it yeah you're late an agent will bill
turd I advised you and that we don't we
don't get that legally but basically we
just cancel his contract yeah and
because he wasn't there yeah and we know
ed gone at first yeah he just
disappeared the police told us so yeah
those are okay okay
Zach low low t9 you see that
ooh ly aut UI light say yep Zach just
moved to the UK I've settled in certain
coming with no money to financially for
it to to FF challenge myself to finally
be challenged its how do you start and
property the first thing you need to do
that get yourself boot on the property
investors crash course is that simple I
think that's where it starts especially
if you're doing it with a little money
and so Nick will put a link to this
somewhere on this video is that possible
Nick thank you very much and get
yourself booked on there's a couple of
spaces I believe June and July we've
just released a date in them just have a
look on the site you'll see I'm on Excel
Excel next month 28th 29th of some dates
available there go get yourself a long
today I will see you there
serenus that's one this one ruse giz
last one last one I've got that right so
Venus apologies not what would you
suggest as the best strategy and setup
for investing and probably in the UK
from abroad not residing in the UK how
to get prepared
what launchpad would work best I have 40
30 30 to 40 thousand pound for a
beginning but best of all want to learn
with no money interestingly we actually
spoke about this we had a lot of the
last crushes we have a lot of
international people so we kind of put
on a bonus we just decided all let's
just do an hour at the end of it just
for those guys to talk a bit about that
it very much depends on your situation
there's kind of two two options so the
one option is you you do what we talked
about earlier in the show you set light
aside a couple of weeks you come over
here you smash it kind of out the park
but the same time you can automate
contact people like solicitors and and
accountants more drugs people like that
and you try and get it all set up in a
short time go back and then let them do
the work for you all the other
alternative is that you use a deal
sorcerer so someone like Alastair for
example runs better sourced they will
find the deal for you but they'll also
give you the power team they'll give you
the builders if it needs work they'll
give you the they give this list to the
mortgage broker even the person to get
the money in the country are very very
low right everything can get set up for
you so you can literally
invest here in the UK get an expert to
find the deal for you and facilitate
everything so from your point of view is
just cash in let them deal with it
and one of the one of the very popular
deals that they tend to look for is to
buy refurbish we find out strategy
because they they've got a lot of money
we'll dump the money in get all the word
don't pull them Ani out and just let
someone else take care of it for them so
anything an interesting thing that I'll
add to that go on if you're an overseas
investor and many people will not take
you seriously unless unless your money's
here because I say especially myself as
a deal sorcerer if I get an overseas
investors come to me and said I want to
buy a deal in the UK I might awesome
great I'll help you but the first thing
we need to know and is that your money's
in the UK and you've got like companies
set up in the UK you've got you've got
something in the UK now if you watch the
video Tube video from a couple of weeks
ago with Sammy I think it was a
thoughtful Thursday he done an interview
with a guy called Robert Joseph Robert
Joseph runs a comic called central FX
and he can facilitate getting your money
here and then they can be their point of
contact for you as an overseas investor
well if for instance if I was to find
you a deal and sell it to you and pass
on to you I would contact raw but I
would facility would facilitate
everything same with builders if you've
got builders and he'd paying he would
they would Pitt go with Robert and he
would facilitate on and it's a much
quicker and easier way to do things and
plus he can get your money here cheaper
than most banks are massively
hope that answers your question guys
thanks ever so much for tuning in don't
forget to subscribe and watch us next
week for our live audience pologize
we'll see you next Saturday at 7 p.m.
see you guys
[Applause]
Oh